[Music]
we live in a vast universe on a small
wet planet where billions of years ago
single-celled life forms evolved from
the same elements as all nonliving
material around them proliferating and
radiating into an incredible array of
complex life forms all of this living in
an adamant microscopic and cosmic is
governed by mathematical laws with
apparently arbitrary constants and this
opens up a question if the universe is
completely governed by these laws
couldn't a powerful enough computer
simulated exactly could our reality
actually be an incredibly detailed
simulation set in place by a much more
advanced civilization this idea may
sound like science fiction but has been
the subject of serious inquiry
philosopher Nick Bostrom advanced a
compelling argument that were likely
living in a simulation and some
scientists also think it's a possibility
these scientists have started thinking
about experimental tests to find out
whether our universe is a simulation
they are hypothesizing about what the
constraints of the simulation might be
and how those constraints could lead to
detectable signs in the world so where
might we look for those glitches one
idea is that as a simulation runs it
might accumulate errors over time to
correct for these errors the simulators
could adjust the constants in the laws
of nature these shifts could be tiny
for instance certain constants we've
measured with accuracies of parts per
million have stayed steady for decades
so any drift would have to be on an even
smaller scale but as we gain more
precision in our measurements in these
constants we might detect slight changes
over time another possible place to look
comes from the concept that find out
computing power no matter how huge can't
simulate infinities if space and time
are continuous then even a tiny piece of
the universe has infinite points and
becomes impossible to simulate with
finite computing power so a simulation
would have to represent space and time
in very small pieces these would be
almost incomprehensible tiny but we
might be able to search for them by
using certain subatomic particles as
probes the basic principle is this the
smaller something is the
more sensitive it will be to disruption
think of hitting a pothole on a
skateboard versus in a truck any unit in
space-time would be so small that most
things would travel through it without
disruption not just objects large enough
to be visible to the naked eye but also
molecules atoms and even electrons and
most of the other subatomic particles
we've discovered if we do discover a
tiny unit in space-time or shifting
constant in a natural law would that
prove the universe is a simulation no it
would only be the first of many steps
there could be other explanations for
each of those findings and a lot more
evidence would be needed to establish
the simulation hypothesis as a working
theory of nature however many tests we
designed were limited by some
assumptions they all share our current
understanding of the natural world on
the quantum level breaks down at what's
known as the Planck scale if the unit of
space-time is on the scale we wouldn't
be able to look for it with our current
scientific understanding there's still a
wide range of things that are smaller
than what's currently observable but
larger than the Planck scale to
investigate similarly shifts in the
constants of natural laws could occur so
slowly that they would only be
observable over the lifetime of the
universe so they could exist even if we
don't detect them over centuries or
millennia of measurements we're also
biased towards thinking that our
universe is simulator if it exists makes
calculations the same way we do with
similar computational limitations really
we have no way of knowing what an alien
civilizations constraints and methods
would be but we have to start somewhere
it may never be possible to prove
conclusively that the universe either is
or isn't a simulation but we'll always
be pushing Science and Technology
forward in pursuit of the question what
is the nature of reality
keep spiraling through the existential
void of life's biggest most bring
busting us questions with these videos
[Music]